you stand up for nothing you'll fought
for everything Gabrielle Union speaks
out amid her million dollar lawsuit
would be et over her being Mary Jane
contract I will never settle for
anything less than what I want and what
I deserve
et chatted with the actress at the LA
premiere of her new film almost
Christmas there's a larger conversation
going on about equality and equal pay
why is it important for you to take the
stand for that issue my mortgage my
mortgage alone
you know I put in the same hours as most
men and if not more and I deserve to get
paid the same equal pay equal works and
that's that's how it should be and if
you if you stand up for nothing you'll
fall for everything
et previously obtained unions complaint
and her attorney explains quote be et
has no right to manipulate the shooting
schedule for the series in this manner
in order to avoid paying plaintiffs the
compensation they are owed I'll take my
chances Gaby also spilled on season
fours sexy line up it's good it's really
easy all kinds of Michael yeah this
season and he's not psychotic or trying
to kill anyone so that's a bonus but
yeah we've got my friend GK who's was in
Birth of a Nation we've got Valerie
Pettifer this season we've got Nicholas
Gonzales this season national and
incredible Casas and then all of the
family that you know and love Luka Vidal
is back it's just very juicy and it's in
New York she's starting over since they
announced it I can finally say we have
cory booker this season we've got dave
east this season for the ladies and
cardi B yeah a fierce lineup yeah it's
all over the place